[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein an einem tag an dem
wir jeden kleinen schritt verfolgen
denen die internationale expertengruppe
der un-atombehörde auf ihre gefährlichen
und ebenso wichtigen missionen macht es
geht um die sicherheit von europas
größtem atomkraftwerk das zu einem
zentrum des russischen krieges in der
ukraine geworden ist es geht um
reaktoren die plötzlich selbst
zielscheibe sind wie schnell da die lage
völlig außer kontrolle geraten könnte
kann sich jeder vorstellen die umstände
dieser mission sind schwerer vorstellbar
und deshalb schauen wir uns das gleich
mal genauer an erst zeigt hannah
hebestreit die bilder von diesem
donnerstag in sapporo ukraine wo der
konvoi der inspektoren das kraftwerk
erreicht hat
kleine gesten können auskunft geben über
große gefühle
ausgerechnet als direktor grossi im
atomkraftwerk unser policia sagt er habe
gesehen was sie sehen musste bemüht sein
russischer gastgeber ross atomexperte
rena karcher den mittelfinger schon am
morgen hatte russland entlang der
fahrtroute und rund um das kraftwerk
waffen sprechen lassen großes mission
passt zum himmelfahrtskommando gemacht
wir glauben dass wir wenigstens ein
minimum an sicherheit haben um zu fahren
wissen aber dass das risiko sehr sehr
hoch ist mein team und ich bin überzeugt
dass wir dieses risiko eingehen müssen
wenn unsere mission ist überaus wichtig
schon nach ein paar kilometern waren
ukrainische militärs nicht überzeugt
dass grossi und seine inspektoren dieses
risiko in der russisch besetzten zone
eingehen sollten sie stoppten den konvoi
am letzten checkpoint
es dauerte stunden ist die
iaea-inspektoren dann doch an europas
grösstem kraftwerk eintrafen der
russische experte von rosatom führte
ihnen erstmal raketen vor
die ukrainische truppen angeblich auf
das kraftwerk abfeuerten fotos sie auch
noch anwohner präsentiert wurden mit
einer petition gegen ukrainische
abpacken
sie können jedem erzählen dass ich das
so annehmen als würde ich ihren stimmen
zu hören die
zeit für die inspektion der anlage hat
das alles geschickt verkürzt trotzdem
hatte grossi schon am nachmittag genug
gesehen
ich bedanke mich dass wir innerhalb
weniger stunden fielen informationen
bekommen haben
das wichtigste was ich sehen musste habe
ich gesehen ihre erläuterungen waren
sehr klar damit war seine mission im
kraftwerk beendet eine handvoll
mitarbeiter bleiben noch bis übermorgen
auch sie selbst hat sich schon ein bild
gemacht
es ist offensichtlich dass die
stabilität der anlage mehrfach
angegriffen wurde
unabsichtlich oder mit vorsatz dafür
haben wir noch nicht genügend belege
aber dieser tatsache müssen wir uns
stellen das darf so nicht weitergehen
groß sie ist jetzt unterwegs nach hause
seine neue mission wie
langfristig am kraftwerk machen zu
lassen
ja die situation vor ort lässt sich
anhand von einer karte besser verstehen
schauen wir sie uns also mal an
russische truppen und die mit ihnen
verbündeten separatisten halten die hier
orange eingefärbten gebiete in der
ukraine
gelb ist das ukrainisch kontrollierte
gebiet hier liegt auch die stadt sabres
ja das atomkraftwerk aber liegt hinter
der front hinter der roten linie das
kraftwerk also in der hand russischer
truppen die stadt sawija die der anlage
ihren namen gegeben hat liegt noch mal
etwa anderthalb autostunden vom
kraftwerk entfernt dort ist erna
hebestreit für uns guten abend herr
wegen der situation dauert die strecke
aber ziemlich lang heute haben die
inspektoren mehrere stunden gebraucht um
dadurch zu kommen das internationale
kontrollteam sagt sie seien gekommen um
einen nuklearen zwischenfall zu
verhindern die erwartungen sind also
hoch die frage ist sind sie erfüllbar
werden wir am ende hannah genau erfahren
wie es um das kraftwerk steht
das ist eine sehr gute frage heute war
das denke ich er mal eine diplomatische
mission vor allem um die iran spiel zu
bringen und im spiel zu halten was die
sicherheit der anlage angeht was du zu
beginn deiner frage gefragt hast hat
sicherlich damit zu tun dass man in der
ukraine schon vorher vor dem krieg
gesagt hat 60 70 prozent aller unfälle
hin zu einem kraftakt menschliches
versagen und stehen die leute die da
arbeiten sechs monaten unter russischer
bewachung leute mit gewehren stehen
teilweise direkt neben ihnen das macht
natürlich stress und so ein stress führt
dann vielleicht zu weiteren fehler wenn
man das jetzt abstellen kann dann hat
die mission schon einen ersten erfolg
jetzt haben in den letzten tagen schon
gemerkt die sache ist natürlich hoch
politisiert der zeitraum den die
inspektoren haben um tatsächlich vor ort
sein zu können ist entscheidend kann man
sich vorstellen wie lange sie bleiben
dürfen die frage ist allerdings wie
lange dürfen sie denn jetzt bleiben der
iaea-chef haben wir gesehen ist schon
wieder weg gibt es da weitere
informationen wie lange diese
inspektoren tatsächlich vor ort sein
können
also unsere informationen bleibt die
kleine gruppe die jetzt noch das bis
samstag also bis übermorgen dann werden
die wohl auch abgezogen aber das ziel
von gosee ist auf jeden fall in nächster
zeit eine neue mission eine langfristige
mission dort zu implementieren wann das
soweit sein wird ist schwer zu sagen
wenn man sich dass das theater heute
morgen angebote wie lange die gebraucht
haben wie kompliziert das alles war wie
gefährlich das alles war dann würde ich
nicht sehr optimistisch dass wir hier
von tagen oder wochen reden kann dann
reden wir bitten auch über die
inhaltlichen punkte was unternehmen denn
die inspektoren jetzt um festzustellen
ob es auf der einen seite erhöhte
strahlung gibt und ob auf der anderen
seite atomare stoffe möglicherweise in
falsche in militärische hände geraten
können versuchen
jetzt habe ich wieder gehört ja also es
ist natürlich immer so dass man die
strahlung in seinem kraftwerk schon mit
geigerzählern irgendwie sehr schnell
ermitteln kann das dürfte also keine
großen zauber reise an der festzustellen
ob der strahlung freigesetzt wird die
zweite frage ist mit dem verschwundenen
mut machst dich vielleicht
verschwundenen atomare material was ja
ein verdacht war den wir hier auch mal
gehört haben das lässt sich alles mit
hilfe von wagen von mikro ragen genau
feststellen denn es ist genau
beschrieben was wo sein muss und wenn
man dann das liegt was man da findet und
four findet dann kann man sehen ist dass
der sollbestand oder war ich der ist
bestand von dem ab was da sein soll und
dann auch henna ich hoffe du hast mich
jetzt besser die gretchenfrage
vielleicht ist dann erwarte dass die
kämpfe tatsächlich enden werden und umso
borussia dass das eine eine zone wird in
der das militär einfach nichts zu suchen
hat
es ist natürlich hier gerade für die
ukraine nicht nur die gretchenfrage
sondern das hauptangebot gewesen
präsident lenski hat sich heute abend
schon sehr enttäuscht geäußert dass
gross über allem was er heute gesagt hat
und er hat ja viel gesagt nichts dazu
gesagt hat ob das militär abgezogen wird
das denke ich wird der prozess einer
langem diplomatischen
auseinandersetzungen auch mit präsident
putin sein den faust fand einer atomaren
in geiselhaft name anderer staaten
vielleicht abhandeln lassen kann aber
das ist
keine hebestreit live in souveräner ganz
herzlichen dank für diese informationen
heute abend
und damit zu unserem nächsten thema ganz
anderes thema unfassbares grauem hut
nazi deutschland im zweiten weltkrieg
über polen gebracht das ist
unbestreitbar städte in trümmern
kulturschätze vernichtet nach dem
deutschen überfall kamen etwa sechs
millionen polen ums leben ihre zahl ist
nur zu schätzen vieles davon wirkt nach
bis heute auch das ist unbestreitbar
aber klar ist auch polen und deutschland
sind mittlerweile freunde und nachbarn
und partner in eu und nato die
nationalkonservativen pis regierung in
warschau sagt jetzt aber wir können
nicht zur tagesordnung übergehen und
kündigt an reparationen zu fordern von
deutschland und zwar in einer immensen
höhe und an einem symbolischen tag exakt
83 jahre heute nach dem deutschen
überfall auf polen hat sie die
kriegsschäden berechnet es seien
1,32 billionen euro aus warschau natalie
steger
teresa stanic war knapp zehn jahre alt
als die deutschen vor 83 jahren polen
überfielen der beginn des zweiten
weltkriegs
als ich die flugzeuge hörte so erinnere
ich es hörte ich keine luftverteidigung
und mein schreiber tatsächlich ein
schrei der sich bis auf die straße trug
also es ist schwer diesen tagen zu
vergessen wenn ein mensch in einem
sommerkleid und st allein zurückbleibt
ohne alles ohne haus
polen und der zweite weltkrieg kein land
hatte so viele tote zu beklagen gemessen
an der gesamtbevölkerung das land
verwüstet die hauptstadt von den
deutschen am ende in schutt und asche
gelegt seit jahren zieht polens
nationalkonservative regierungspartei
das thema reparationszahlungen nach oben
nun der vorläufige höhepunkt im
warschauer königsschloss von den
deutschen 1 zerstört originalgetreu
wieder aufgebaut in einer großen
inszenierung berechnet polen die schäden
zusammen auf etwa 1,3 millionen euro
wir haben auch die entscheidung
getroffen was die weiteren handlungen
betrifft als das ist das hinwenden an
deutschland um verhandlungen zu beginnen
in sachen reparationen
etwa die hälfte der polen unterstützt
das laut aktueller umfrage die pis will
mit dem thema über parteigrenzen hinweg
punkten das leid unter nazi deutschland
ist im kollektiven gedächtnis
sie sollten uns alles zurückgeben sie
haben uns so viel leid zugefügt es steht
uns zu und ende
sie sollen es endlich kapieren so viele
haben sie ermordet so viel haben sie im
land vernichtet das ist ein historisches
anliegen und lange her man sollte sich
nicht an solchen dingen aufhängen
1953 verzichtet die kommunistische
volksrepublik polen verbindlich auf
reparationen berlin lehnt jegliche
warschauer forderung ab deutschland habe
nach dem krieg gezahlt an staaten des
damaligen ostblocks und polen habe
damals für gebietsverluste im osten
wiederum deutschen ostgebiete erhalten
außerdem verweist berlin auf den zwei
plus vier vertrag zur wiedervereinigung
das thema sei juristisch abgeschlossen
was man den deutschen vorschlagen könnte
ist sich nicht hinter juristischen
formeln und verfahren zu verstecken
sondern eine geste zu machen die
deutsch-polnischen gespräch erleichtert
aber etwa historische projekte seitens
deutschland freiwillig zu finanzieren
reicht der pis nicht es geht um mehr als
ums geld meint die opposition
jahreswagen ski versteckt es nicht dass
sie auf basis der antideutschen kampagne
die unterstützung für die regierende
partei ausbauen möchten
dauerthema reparationszahlungen
juristisch das dürfte auch die pis
wissen ein langer wohl ein möglicher weg
vielleicht sollten wir etwas bekommen
nur muss man die angemessene zeit und
form finden angemessenes verständnis das
darf nicht so sein dass wir anfangen uns
zu streiten
sagt versöhnlich die die das hüten der
deutschen erlebt hat keinen konflikt
wünscht sie sich aber durchaus gesten
von deutschland vielleicht ist sie damit
viel sensibler als die politik 83 jahre
nach weltkriegs beginn
die laute politik und eine leise
weltkriegs überlebende
so und jetzt in der sendung johanna mit
dem blick auf das was heute auch noch
wichtig ist ab heute heißt das
energiesparen in deutschland angesichts
der gasknappheit hat die bundesregierung
eine energiespar verordnung erlassen die
jetzt in kraft getreten ist das bedeutet
zum beispiel dass öffentliche gebäude
nur noch bis höchstens 19 grad beheizt
werden ausgenommen soziale einrichtungen
und dass die beleuchtung von denkmälern
ausgeschaltet wird ladentüren müssen
geschlossen bleiben leuchtreklamen
sollen zwischen 22 und 16 uhr ausbleiben
und zudem werden klauseln in
mietverträgen die eine mindesttemperatur
vorsehen erst mal ausgesetzt
der bundesrechnungshof hat deutliche
kritik am entwurf für den bundeshaushalt
2010 und 20 geäußert die wahre lage der
bundesfinanzen werde aus dem
haushaltsentwurf nicht deutlich heißt es
in einem bericht des bundesrechnungshofs
die echte nettokreditaufnahme sei mit
rund 78 milliarden euro 4 fach höher als
im etat ausgewiesen dort ist für das
kommende jahr nur ein neuverschuldung
von 17,2 milliarden euro aufgeführt
nächste woche befasst sich der bundestag
mit dem entwurf
pflegekräften in pflegeeinrichtungen und
bei pflegediensten müssen seit heute
löhne auf tarifniveau gezahlt werden
damit steigt ihre entlohnung nach
schätzungen private einrichtungsträger
um bis zu 30 prozent je nach bundesland
und einrichtungen patientenvertreter und
gewerkschaften bemängeln jedoch die
mehrkosten würden bislang hauptsächlich
von den pflegebedürftigen getragen
steigerungen um mehrere hundert euro im
monat brächten viele in existenzielle
not erforderlich sei deswegen eine
deckelung oder ein fester eigenanteil
die europäische arzneimittelagentur ema
hat zwei angepasste omikron impfstoffe
von bayern tag und moderner zugelassen
nun muss noch die europäische kommission
zustimmen was allerdings als formsache
gilt die beiden impfstoffe sollen neben
dem ursprünglichen virus stammen auch
gegen die omikron unter variante br 1
einen schutz bieten allerdings wurde
dieser subtyp mittlerweile von anderen
untervarianten verdrängt ein angepasster
impfstoff gegen diese soll
voraussichtlich im herbst zur verfügung
stehen
das russische militär hat inmitten des
angriffskriegs gegen die ukraine
gemeinsam mit china und weiteren staaten
ein militärmanöver im osten russlands
gestartet an der großangelegten übung
sind laut moskau mehr als 50.000
soldaten
140 flugzeuge und 60 kriegsschiffe
beteiligt unter anderem auch aus belarus
syrien und indien peking erklärte die
übung solle die freundschaftliche
zusammenarbeit der streitkräfte
vertiefen
man kann den druck nur erahnen unter
denen die hochkommissarin für
menschenrechte der weltgemeinschaft
selbst geraten ist china wollte mit
aller macht verhindern dass ihr bericht
über menschenrechtsverstöße gegen die
minderheit der uiguren
veröffentlicht wird und die machthaber
in peking hätten es fast geschafft
aber dann gestern abend 23 uhr 52 exakt
acht minuten bevor die vierjährige
amtszeit der uno kommissarin abläuft
kommt der bericht und er hat es in sich
es gab schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen steht da kein
konjunktiv mehr die hinweise auf folter
misshandlung und sexualisierte gewalt
seien glaubwürdig miriam stein berichtet
so sieht es aus wenn das chinesische
staatsfernsehen aus china berichtet
präsident jean ping lässt die
muslimische minderheit in der provinz im
nordwesten chinas für sich tanzen so
sieht es aus wenn fotos aus internen
polizeiberichten durch gestochen werden
wenn die abstrakten berichte von
massenhaften inhaftierungen von uiguren
und anderen minderheiten ein gesicht
bekommen viele gesichter das war im mai
als die un menschenrechtskommissarin zu
besuch in china war und unter anderem
für diese szene viel kritik bekam
ihr wurde ein buch überreicht campings
gedanken zu menschenrechten und die
chinesische presse hat das ganze
geschichte zelebriert und gefeiert denn
eigentlich wurde erwartet dass umgekehrt
die un kommissarin ihre gedanken
beziehungsweise kritik zu den
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china
übergibt das hat sie jetzt nachgeholt an
ihrem letzten tag im amt veröffentlichte
sie den lange erwarteten bericht die
zusammenfassung sagt dass ernsthaft den
menschenrechtsverletzungen begangen
wurden der bericht sagt dass
möglicherweise verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit begangen wurden das sind
alles sehr
aussagekräftige
statements vielen reicht das nicht mit
ihrer jüngsten tochter kam sie 2017 in
die türkei von ihrem mann und den beiden
anderen kindern in den young hat sie
seither nichts gehört
die welt sieht die feindseligkeit chinas
aber sie reagiert nicht sie bleibt still
wir sind sehr verärgert
auch die rikscha bielesch ist in china
geboren inzwischen lebt er in den usa
und sammelt berichte von menschen die
zwangsarbeit oder
zwangssterilisationen selbst erlebt
haben er ist wütend
ich bin so enttäuscht
warum haben alle un mitglieder in den
letzten fünf jahren geschlafen während
millionen unschuldige von ethnischen
minderheiten verhaftet und getötet
wurden die führung in peking bezeichnet
die lager in kenia als schulungszentren
aufgebaut für den kampf gegen
extremismus wurde der sogenannte bericht
ist von den usa und anderen westlichen
kräften inszeniert und erstellt worden
völlig illegal und ungültig
sein scheint weit weg zu sein der
überwachungsstaat in china hier
errichtet könnte aber als blaupause
dienen das natürlich auch methoden und
techniken die man in anderen kontexten
gegen andere gruppen gegen dissidenten
gegen religiöse minderheiten einsetzen
kann michelle bachelet veröffentlichte
ihren bericht acht minuten vor
mitternacht acht minuten vor ende ihrer
amtszeit als hochkommissarin für
menschenrechte eine nachfolgerin oder
einen nachfolger gibt es noch nicht
nach deutschland zuversicht von der
zugspitze statt mutlosigkeit aus
meseberg wenn jemand sich an derartige
alliterationen wagt wie bayerns csu
landesgruppenchef alexander dobrindt
heute dann ist das entweder interessante
inspiration in gesunder gipfel luft oder
wahrscheinlicher stramme strategie weil
auch die opposition ihre vorstellungen
hat was jetzt zu tun wäre in deutschland
beziehungsweise was nicht und weil sie
damit auffallen und punkten will die
fraktionsspitzen von cdu und csu waren
heute in klausur auf der zugspitze und
fordern ein aus für die gasanlage bevor
sie in kraft tritt mehr von alexander
pohl wenn politiker auf die zugspitze
laden dann tun sie dies in erwartung
spektakulärer bilder
und der absicht eine starke botschaft
auszusenden oder was immer sie dafür
halten
deutschland braucht zuversicht von der
zugspitze statt der mutlosigkeit aus
meesiger eine anspielung auf die
kabinettsklausur der bundesregierung
doch deutschlands höchster berg
verweigert sich heute der gewollten
inszenierung das wetter spielt nicht mit
der vorsitzende der größten
oppositionsfraktion versucht es mit
autosuggestion mit der union geduld
haben aber dann bricht die sonne durch
sie tut es nicht und so müssen friedrich
merz und alexander dobrindt ihre kritik
an der ampel koalition vor einer grauen
nebelwand kundtun was die stimmung
dieser tage ja irgendwie auch ganz gut
trifft
wir sind überrascht und erstaunt darüber
dass diese klausurtagung des kabinetts
über zwei tage
praktisch ergebnislos zu ende gegangen
ist wenn man sich die preisentwicklung
anschaut an der tankstelle beim strom
bei der wärme dann wird für viele
familien sich die frage stellen ob am
ende eines monats der kühlschrank voll
oder leer ist konkrete
entlastungsschritte der ampel wie etwa
die energie pauschale kritisiert die
union als strohfeuer auf ihrer
klausurtagung sprechen sich die
abgeordneten für eine gezielte
entlastung mittlerer einkommen aus wer
als single unter 30.000 oder als ehepaar
unter 60.000 euro verdient soll in den
kommenden beiden jahren für jedes kind
1000 euro bekommen vorgeschlagen wird
auch ein steuerfreibetrag von 3000 euro
und um die grundversorgung mit gas zu
sichern soll der preis gedeckelt werden
ein preis deckel wäre ein instrument das
in frage käme es ist nicht sehr
marktwirtschaftlich aber in einer
solchen situation wo der markt ohnehin
durch die verknappung von gas so
komplett aus dem tritt geraten ist kann
man meines erachtens auch über ein
solches instrument reden bürger
basispreis nennt die union ihr
instrument manche volkswirte nennen es
giesst kann
auch dieser basis grundtarif würde jetzt
ja allen privaten haushalten zur
verfügung stehen also auch hier würden
staatliche mittel nicht konzentriert
eingesetzt dort wo sie besonders
dringend gebraucht werden morgen will
die unions fraktion ihre tagung
fortsetzen dann aber im tal wo das
wetter hoffentlich besser ist
in exakt vier stunden sagen die ohne die
kein lufthansa-jet abheben kann liebes
management so nicht nicht mit uns die
pilotengewerkschaft vereinigung cockpit
hat die piloten und piloten zum streik
aufgerufen
ein großteil der lh flüge in deutschland
fällt aus darunter fast alle in
frankfurt und münchen peter wagner ist
für uns am frankfurter flughafen gut
namen peter
130.000 passagiere sind betroffen
was heißt das denn für die jetzt konkret
ja also der überwiegende teil dieser
130.000 passagiere wird morgen nicht
fliegen können sondern erst samstag weg
oder zurück nach hause kommen fast alle
maschinen bleiben nämlich heute abend
dort stehen wo sie samstagfrüh gebraucht
werden damit dann am samstag der
flugplan wieder reibungslos
funktionieren kann die lufthansa bemüht
sich natürlich passagiere auf andere
fluglinien umzubuchen oder innerdeutsche
auf die bahn aber das wird nur einem
kleinen teil helfen und wer für morgen
ein ticket hat und das noch nicht getan
hat sollte sich auf jeden fall dringend
informieren wie es weitergeht und kann
man sich darauf verlassen dass es
tatsächlich nach diesem einen tag vorbei
ist oder wird sich das länger hinziehen
also ich glaube auch nach den
erfahrungen mit dem verdi streikt vor
vier wochen dass das jetzt hier kein
endloser arbeitskampf wird streiks sind
katastrophal fürs image und gefährden
natürlich auch langfristig den erfolg
des unternehmens lufthansa das wissen
auch beide seiten und sie wissen vor
allem dass diese arbeitskampf schwer zu
vermitteln ist an die kundschaft und an
die öffentlichkeit die piloten weil
nämlich sie nicht gerade zu den
geringverdienern gehören und die
lufthansa weil sie im wettbewerb endlich
den
als streik hansa loswerden muss also ich
glaube dass da bald neue gespräche
stattfinden und dass man ernsthaft nach
einer lösung suchen wird peter wagner
hat vom frankfurter flughafen heute
abend kurz bevor der streik beginnen
soll herzlichen dank peter das sind die
wirkungen und folgen mitten in der
hochsaison
es kommt ja noch dazu mehr zu den
hintergründen jetzt bei diana auf diesen
festgefahrenen konflikt wollen wir jetzt
noch mal genauer schauen die piloten
fordern 5,5 prozent mehr lohn und einen
automatisierten
inflationsausgleich das weiß die
lufthansa zurück und bietet monatlich
pauschal 900 euro für eine laufzeit von
eineinhalb jahren
aber es geht den piloten eben nicht nur
um mehr geld sondern auch ganz
grundsätzlich um die tarifstruktur und
die strategie der lufthansa stephanie
beckert in frankfurt was kritisieren die
piloten da genau also im grunde fürchten
piloten und pilotinnen der lufthansa
eine zweiklassengesellschaft bei den
cockpit gehältern der in europas größte
airline hat ein problem mit den kurz und
mittelstreckenflügen sie kosten viel und
bringen wenig gewinn ein durch zukäufe
hat sie nun neue flugbetriebe mit
niedrigeren tarif bedingungen geschaffen
schon jetzt sind die gehaltsunterschiede
aber deutlich steigt man bei der
lufthansa im cockpit mit
69.000 euro ein und verdient als kapitän
dann bis zu 275 1000 euro so starten
piloten und pilotinnen bei eur rings
etwa mit 59.000 euro erreichen aber bei
167.000 dann auch das maximum immerhin
ein unterschied von über 100.000 euro
die pilotengewerkschaft sieht hier nun
einen schleichenden prozess immer mehr
flüge von der lufthansa auf günstigere
tochtergesellschaften zu verlagern um
personalkosten einzusparen
am ende könnte dann eine kern lufthansa
als reine langstrecken airline stehen
hier sprudeln nämlich die gewinne und
die hohen gehälter fallen da auch nicht
so ins gewicht und bietet die lufthansa
den piloten jahr 900 euro pro monat mehr
wie ist denn dieses angebot
einzuschätzen also so oder so dürfte
dieser tarifkonflikt die lufthansa teuer
zu stehen kommen ein tarifpaket mit 900
euro mehr im monat für die 5000 piloten
würde hunderte von millionen euro kosten
streiks wären aber ebenso kostspielig
der letzte jahrelange arbeitskampf
kostete die lufthansa am ende etwa 500
millionen euro und nicht zuletzt kratzen
natürlich auch flugausfälle am image
dennoch fallen die forderungen der
piloten und pilotinnen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt sicher aus dem rahmen und
streiks dürften auch gerade zum
ferienende jetzt auf wenig verständnis
bei normalverdienern stoßen nicht nur
die lufthansa-aktie fehle heute durch
der dax insgesamt legte er einen
missglückten start in den september hin
und verlor gut 200 punkte auf 12.600 30
zähler zu unsicher erscheinen derzeit
die konjunkturaussichten das spiegelt
sich im auch in den kursen wider vielen
dank stefanie nach frankfurt
und in unserem heute journal update gibt
es später noch ein gespräch mit dem
sprecher der pilotengewerkschaft
vereinigung cockpit zu diesem thema
seit mitternacht ist schluss mit dem
tank rabatt und das hat direkte
konsequenzen an den zapfsäulen
die spritpreise sind sprunghaft
gestiegen laut adac kostete ein liter
e10 am nachmittag durchschnittlich etwa
22 cent mehr als am vortag beim diesel
lag das plus bei rund 18 bereits in den
vergangenen zwei wochen waren die
spritpreise wieder deutlich gestiegen
lange galt die emscher als dreckigste
fluss deutschlands heute wurde ihre
aufwändige und jahrzehntelange
renaturierung mit einem festakt
gewürdigt über 170 jahre lang flossen
haushalts und industrieabwässer aus dem
ruhrgebiet in die emscher denn
unterirdischer abwasserleitungen gab es
bergbau bedingt lange nicht bis anfang
der neunzigerjahre damit begonnen wurde
wir 130 kilometer abwasserkanäle vier
große kläranlagen und dreipunkt werke zu
bauen kosten über 5,5 milliarden euro
die emscher und ihre nebenflüsse wieder
naturnah umzugestalten soll noch bis
2027 dauern
beim trifft die präsidentin der eu
kommission auf luisa neubauer von
fridays for future ampel unter druck ist
das thema keine strategie in der
energiekrise
fragezeichen das gleich hier im zdf nach
und es lohnt sich und wir wünschen ihnen
jetzt noch einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend heute ist meteorologische
herbstanfang viele bäume sehen wegen der
anhaltenden trockenheit aber schon
länger so aus als wäre es herbst denn
bäume nehmen über ihre wurzeln wasser
auf und verteilen es bis in die blätter
hier verdunstet es während sie co2 für
die photosynthese aufnehmen können die
wurzeln kein wasser mehr liefern
versucht der baum das verdunsten zu
verhindern und stellt die photosynthese
1 die blätter werden braun eichen werfen
zum beispiel auch früchte und zweige ab
meist treiben die erste im folgejahr
zwar wieder aus aber mit kleineren
schwächeren blättern und das ist
problematisch wenn die trockenheit
länger andauert
darauf müssen wir uns im zuge der
klimakrise nun einmal einstellen wir
kommen zum wetter es ist meist klar
heute nacht und wir haben diesen
trockenen ostwind mit dem es super
auskühlen kann vor allem in der
osthälfte auf 12 bis 7 grad nur morgen
früh westen bleibt es milder mit 15 bis
12 grad morgen ist es dann im osten eher
herbstlich mit 20 bis 22 grad im westen
durchaus sommerlich mit 24 bis 28 grad
dazu gibt es ein tag mit viel sonne nur
harmlosen quellwolken einigen tropfen
regen an der ostsee und weiter diesem
frischem ostwind erst abends werden von
südwesten die wolken dichter und es gibt
schauer und gewitter die am samstag im
ganzen südwesten auch durchaus kräftig
ausfallen können tschüss